pour vous vos bienvenue sur diagonale tv
pour ce championnat du monde d'échecs
carsen à nantes championnat 2014 avec
donc le champion du monde magnus carsen
16e du nom face à un homme le challenger
donc le champion sortant qui revient
donc dans ce match les joueurs sont à
égalité avant cette partie numéro 6 1
partout partie importante puisqu'on est
à mi match le match jouant en 12 parties
et sans doute des tie break en cas
d'égalité faudra vérifier ça donc la
sixième partie très importante car ce n
allais blanc est ce que on va à revoir
une ouverture déjà tenté par l'un ou par
l'autre sans doute pas puisque carsen
fait tout pour éviter de rejouer les
mêmes d'ariane justement donc on y va on
va voir ce qui va se passer dans celle
là bien en tout cas eu 80 la carson qui
dévie pas dans ce match qui a toujours
pour l'instant joué eu 4 un an de
réplique par ces 5
donc là on revient sur la dernière
partie où carson avait des blancs
gabriel 3e 6 tout ça est normal et la d4
alors voilà donc la sicilienne je dirais
est normal ouverte alors que carsen
allait tenter autre chose à la fois
précédente vous invite à revoir à la
partie numéro 4 est donc qu on prend
cavale et prend à 6,2 à nantes voilà
déjà un choix jouer à 6 alors que
d'autres coûts sont possibles comme dans
cette position mais sûr on peut jouer
cavalier ici en c6 on peut jouer bien
sûr cavaliers f6 pourquoi pas tenter de
faire pousser leurs pions blancs 1,5
voire des si c'est possible aussi
mais évidemment le coup aussi c'est
possible et le coût que je vous car
c'est maintenant ces quatre classiques
cercil et noir laisse un peu faire bon
mais on peut installer ici c'est ce qui
c'est le cas avec locaux à 6 on peut
installer ce qu'on appelle un étau de
maroc si ça s'appelle un étonnement roxy
pourquoi un étau bon c'est contre la
poussée des 5
voilà c'est un étau qui empêche la
maintenant si les noirs jouent des cinq
bas il y aura des échanges au centre
avec des pions isolés possibles et des
problématiques après pour pour les noirs
c'est donc c'est très difficile pour les
noirs de se libérer facilement au centre
maintenant le problème c'est que ce coût
mais perdu dans tant de développement le
pion et sur blanc et il va y avoir des
petits pots il peut y avoir des
problèmes sur les cases noires affaibli
maintenant ici parce qu'on a joué quand
même beaucoup de piano ouverture aussi
on a perdu un peu de temps donc on va
voir la suite cavaliers six attaques le
pion aux 4 et maintenant alors bien sûr
on peut envisager un coup comme par
exemple regarder le e5
c'est un piège classique j'attaque le
cas les 6 mai regardez là danois
reviendrait en a cinq échecs au roi et
une fois que les bleus ont paré l'échec
on va gober le pion aux cercles donc
attention et c'est un piège qu'il faut
évidemment éviter alors personne tombe
pas dans le piège
ils jouent pas eu cinq bien entendu il
joue la variante plus logique et bien
entendu qu'avait laissé trois jeux call
et ses 3 ce qui est normal on défend le
pion et la foulée quatre ans que j'ai
utilisées c'est que bombay effectivement
je cloud le cavalier le roi est derrière
donc le plan 4 est de nouveau attaqué
c'est à dire que la la menace c'est
calais prend le cas de gale un pion donc
il faut faire attention dans le détroit
est logique
voilà on met la dame sur une bonne case
en d3 protège le 4 protège le cavalier
c'est bien on a sorti la dame
c'est un erreur coût de cette position
parce que là si on joue un coup comme
passif comme f3 qui affaiblit encore une
fois les cases noires sans doute les
noirs peuvent se libérer très vite par
des cinq et il peut y avoir des menaces
assez assez vite pénible
il faut faire gaffe donc il faut quand
même développé ces pièces aussi du coût
des noirs maintenant qu avait laissé 6
on développe une pièce normal
bombay blanc maintenant ont plein de
encore une possibilité on va pas les
commenter tout pourrait jouer sous ios4
on pourrait aussi tenté de questionner
le fou parra 3 mai
bon sur foot rend on est quasiment
obligé de prendre du plomb quand même
puisque le puits en 4 sera attaqué sinon
si on prend de la dame donc c'est un peu
chaud donc la personne ne choisit une
variante simplificatrice alors typique
un peu de son style tenter enfin pas
tenté mais a transposé dans des finales
où il a il peut obtenir un petit
avantage et jouer sur sa très très
grande technique ton très grand sens
positionnelle en finale regard décalé
processus alors là on a chois avec les
noirs soit dépensé 6 soit des princes et
six bombes et prend 6,6 et le coup qui
semblait naturel puisque on rapproche
champion du centre mais la poussée des
cinq est rendue délicate à cause de ces
deux fameux piano marc oxylane donc bon
pourquoi pas des princes et si c'est
quand même le coup normal on consolide
au centre et puis on préparera une
poussée des cinq rues intérieures
pourquoi pas mais un an de choisi de
rentrer quand même alors là ça m'étonne
c'est comme la défense de berlin delà de
la première partie fin de la seconde
plus tôt c'est un nombre à l'eiblen les
parties elle perd ou effectivement un
monde avait joué la défense de berlin
qui est transposée dans une finale où
carsen la l'a emporté donc la
transposition dans une quasi finale
après d'un programme quand tu as pu les
dames en général on considère que c'est
déjà presque une finale reprend donc
final ça veut dire que ben les dangers
de maths sont presque éliminé et
quasiment donc c'est une partie de
manoeuvre à moyen long terme et la e500
carsen alors sans doute une préparation
bien sûr le pion aux 5 et bien parce que
ils chassent banc lecavalier 6 qui a
attaqué depuis un an quatre toute façon
un autre coup était pas évident dans
cette position on va prendre des huit
bons on peut envisager de jouer un coup
qu'on fout des trois c'est possible
protège 2.4 bon mais c'est possible bien
sûr aussi 5 et dynamique alors
l'avantagent aussi 2,5 c'est que ça à en
faire le fou s'est vite c'est sans doute
l'idée positionnelle derrière ce coup se
foule pas près de sortir parce que bon
17,8 et y fait rien et puis il ya les
pions sur sur blanc donc avant de les
bouger de sortir le fou il va se passer
des choses
donc si un coup fortement positionnelle
secousses inc hélas non de vie dans les
questionner sur son cavalier alors il ya
beaucoup qui viennent à l'esprit voire
peut-être même trois je peux envisager
qu'un léger quatre attaques le pion aux
cinq bons mais après faut f4 on
attaquera le cavalier qui sera obligé de
venir enrichissent par exemple on pourra
faire [ __ ] en pions prend avec une
structure cassé sa part est pas terrible
terrible quand même il faut être quatre
voire quatre ans signe un salaire
jouable aussi et l'autre coup qui paraît
comme un naturel mais que joue pas alors
on va voir c'est quand même le coup qu'a
lieu 4-4-1-1 naturel dans cette position
que fernande pourquoi il joue pas ce
coup là quand même
kb24 augmente la pression sur calais
c'est 3,5 ou absolument naturel alors là
si les noirs jouent par exemple ou des
deux bons c'est possible mais
on peut simplement prendre le fou pour
apprend et puis on a la paire de fou on
n'est même pas obligé de prendre le
cavalier on peut sortir le roi par
exemple en hausse est de 1 c'est cette
île est sûre cases noires donc ils
risquent plus rien plus efficacement
on va faire un fou échec on va essayer
de on va faire pendant deux tours échec
peut-être ont barré en enlever le fou
pourquoi pour jouer b6 ses 500 cloud
soit enfermé parce que si on vous b6 et
5 je fous sera fermé en essayant de
garder le fou en libérant le fou en
baisse est bon c'est un plan à long
terme
bon ça paraissait tout à fait jouable et
l'a donc jouer un coup je suis pas un
peu curieux qui a aidé cette moi j'aime
pas trop secours parce que calais 17
rebonds des gens ferment un peu plus le
fossé vite je libère pas la colonne des
pour les tours bon certes j'attaque le
pion 5 ben c'est vrai alors là il ya
deux façons maintenant de défendre quand
même ici c'est soit de jouer f4 bon avec
4 est possible dans ce cas là à bombay
le fou ici se développera peut-être sur
la case de 3,20 c'est peut-être pas ce
que veut faire un quart scène qui joue
un coup étonnant lui aussi c'est
difficile cette partie quand même poule
4 voilà un coût qui paraît un peu
curieux parce qu'on a souvent envie de
défendre le pion avancé du d'un pion
alors lignes de cars scène c'est
peut-être de se dire bon se fout pourra
pas facilement attaquée aux cinq co que
bombay pour rejouer en a cinq
et on sait cette ses joues abl
on pourrait aussi augmenter la pression
sur scène qu'en jouant rives 6 pourquoi
pas un jouet f6 on force les blancs
presque à prendre prise prise et puis
bon on a un pion central on va jouer
scène qui va chasser le fou ça paraît
jouable aussi c'est difficile fouet 4
bon pourquoi pas pour les avantages
qu'on a sorti le fou on prépare le grand
roque
pourquoi pas avec la tour en face du roi
c'est pas si mal et là anne andjou le
curieux alors que ça presse pains
il va jouer fou prend cavaliers c3 bon
pourquoi pas ce que c'était vraiment
urgent de le faire à ce moment-là je
sais pas peut-être qu'il veut jouer m6
puis on prend bien on prend et alors en
quoi ça empêche
bon je sais pas il faut penser 3b prend
l'avantagé brands pour les noirs ici
d'assez de doubler les plans blancs sa
session très bien mais les blancs la
fameuse paire de fou bon la position
n'est pas super ouverte c'est pas sur ce
soit en gros avantage donc peut-être que
c'est bien pour les noirs en terme de
structure c'est vrai que bon maintenant
le fou s'est vite [ __ ] et il y aurait
il est toujours en veut il n'a pas
trouvé de cases
alors si on joue un v6 avec les noirs
suivi de ces 5 fu 17 c'est bien mais en
jouant b6 et celle qu'on enlève des
cases aux cavaliers il va où maintenant
le cavalier c'est le cas délicat des
problèmes bon peut-être il peut se
recycler paraît fuite et j'ai six
attaquants le fouet pions mais après fou
g3 il ya des h 4 h 5 et puis le carré a
toujours pas de case intéressante donc
difficile pour les noirs en fait de
développer leurs pièces mineurs dont le
roi sait c'est normal moi c'est cette
prépare le la liaison des tours mais
après qu'on ait réussi à trouver une
façon de bouger ce fou s'est vite alors
là car senna doit pas traîner parce que
positionnement sa position quand une
poubelle c'est à dire qu'aucun des pions
doublé bon c'est pas terrible mais il a
la paire de fou et on va voir qui va
arriver à
bénéficiez de son seul avantage dans
cette ouverture là c'est une meilleure
facilité de sortir ces pièces se fout
notamment peuvent venir en d3 bon il
tape sur du vide faire une tape sur une
planchette qui équipent protéger
facilement manquer mais il va pouvoir
aussi faire le grand roque
éventuellement activer ses tours par
exemple sur la troisième
on a déjà vu une possibilité d'activer
les tours sur la troisième dans une des
parties du championnat du monde c'est
quoi ici par exemple acquis pour venir
ici attaquer ses pions bon donc si
l'idée des blancs c'est d'aller attaquer
ses pions le coût de 400 se comprend h4
voilà alors h4 belle idée c'est gagner
l'espace de ce côté là c'est là où les
noirs basson ont une cible à ses pions
constitue une cible pourquoi pas puisque
on peut mettre les tours sur la
troisième les attaquer h 5 h 6 essayer
de a joué cinq à six pour affaiblir la
structure si les noirs jouent ici s'ils
ont affaibli leurs cases noires
peut-être ou peut-être simplement h5
qu'on veut même pas jouer h6 jouage
c'est comme ça après tout la tour là où
l'autre tour c'est long mais c'est
jouable on force et noir jouent ici
c'est après la prise on a deux tours qui
attaquent les pions noirs et qui peuvent
pénétrer dans le camp adverse
c'est long mais les noirs pour sortir
leur pièce c'est long aussi
voilà donc ce qui est long pour l'un et
l'ont aussi pour l'autre donc b6 why he
can't handle me l'a compris traîne pas
b6 valider ce évite de sortir ce fou de
lier les taux ainsi les tours doivent
venir protéger par la passe qu'il va se
passer les choses il faut il faut sortir
le fouet le cavalier il n'a pas de case
intéressante à sa disposition donc il
n'y a pas trop de choix fauves sortie en
17 h 5 continue à gagner de l'espace
il n'y a pas de menace directe là un
homme décide de stopper le pion h6 bon
est ce que vraiment c'est vraiment une
idée nécessaire serment je suis pas sûr
c'est difficile là c'est pas tactique 1
c'est que ces positionnelle bon est ce
que les noirs ont pas intérêt à laisser
jouer j'ai 6 h 5 g 6 puisque après h5 g6
bon c'est vrai que c'est difficile pour
les blancs de progresser là le plonge
ici c'est très très fort
comment l'attaqué on peut pas on peut
envisager d'attaquer cette donc jouer
tourache trois tours f3 cette fois et cf
s'être qui peut faire l'objet d'une
petite pression
est ce qu'on peut vraiment ajouter
beaucoup doutent beaucoup de pièces sur
f7 c'est pas sûr c'est pas sûr donc h6
pourquoi pas bon au moins on bloque le
pion mais on a fait bill puis angers
cède du coup voilà c'est ça ce pion là
c'est peut-être un peu un peu tendu un
bon grand rôle à part car scène c'est
logique le bon l'idée c'est d'amener la
twa vers le centre on veut très
certainement joué tour h3 touché 3 et
peut-être mettre l'autre tour sur h 4 ou
linverse venir sur des quatre le tour
sur g3 mais les noirs vont jouer ces
scènes très probablement très très vite
aussi donc fou 17
bon ben j'ai un petit oeil par là mais
bon pour l'instant c'est sur un g2 c'est
pas une bravery menace d'autant qu'après
tour des 3 c 5 voilà évidemment le
naturel c'est ton j'ai transgressé en un
mois c'est à dire que là les noirs en
jouant h6 finalement voilà il aurait pu
jouer ils n'auraient plus rien faire en
fait est là maintenant surtout tôt là il
aurait pu se défendre comme dans la
partie soit même joué g6 et après pillon
prendre puis on prend le bambin les
tours sont liés donc les noirs
risquaient rien sur la colonne h
ce que les blancs auraient pu doubler ou
si c'est vrai les blancs auraient pu
doubler dans ce cas là la colonne
acheter une pénétration avec la pression
la mine de rien c'est simple le plan de
carsen mais bon ça ça pose des petits
soucis quand il nya pression donc la
tour un g8 pour ça c'est l'étonnante
pourquoi cette tour alors on peut
revenir en arrière
imaginons qu'on fasse tourache g8 et ça
pose un petit souci parce que l'idée est
la suivante simplement joujou fou des 3t
je menace devenir h7 est là si la tour
bouge pouf qu'angers septembre là autant
dire que si j'ai cette tombe c'est
terminé donc là avec rien car ce n
arrive à mettre les noms en difficulté
c'est terrible c'est terrible donc j'ai
trois donc la torah g8 l'ong l'idée
c'est que je garde la tourache 8 pour
garder la case h7 en cas de foot est roi
bel atour protège assène je peux pas
venir à jeun
on pèche pas fou détroit maintenant que
la tour et angers 3 pourquoi parce que
je protège bien sûr j'ai de faux papiers
qui est fou j'ai des 17 qui attaque et
g2 donc j'ai attendu d'avoir la tour en
g3 pour sortir le fuji 2 alors regardez
comme toutes les pièces blanches sans du
côté dames le fou attaque ici cette
diagonale le fond f4 attaques sur ses
diagonales latour attaque sur la grande
colonne et sept tours n'attend plus que
de venir h4 est peut-être doubler en
doublant g4 pouf
comment protège h7 comment protéger
cette pardon en doublant g4 ici deux
tours ici comment protège voyez c'est
long mais que faire et des fois les
plans c'est pas parce qu'ils sont longs
qu'ils sont pas puissants donc avait
créé un bon un homme qui fait des petits
coups un peu curieux lâche 6 banques
dire qu'il n'a pas joué cavalier ou 4 au
début cavalaire quand même d'être un
coup à la fois naturel fort ou et
bizarrement ce début olemps et il se
retrouve tout de suite en difficulté
calais fuite bon pourquoi pas mais comme
on l'a dit alors le sentiment qu'il n'y
ait pas de casse bon mais la réfuter ce
qu'il est bien mais j'ai pas
l'impression
qu'est ce qu'ils foutent le crédit
suisse alors peut-être qu'il veut venir
en âge 7
qu'est-ce qui vient [ __ ] en achètent
ou six pattes c'est terrible parce que
morale cette île venir quoi angers scène
mais unis perdu dans ce cas la fin on
perd un pion oui c'est des coups aux
certes c'est des coups est ce que le nom
en d'autres coups c'est le problème est
ce que déjà les noirs sont pas mal quoi
déjà est ce que les noirs sont pas dans
une position intenable
en tout cas c'est dur voyez que les
pions doublé l'a finalement les noirs
peuvent rien faire pour l'instant
pour en profiter ils ont rien pu faire
depuis le début on peut le temps tout
simplement
donc c'est fou hein c'est fou de voir
cette position-là déjà fou et 3
tranquille
j'attends je sais pas pourquoi or et
noir en jouant fouet trois empêche des
manoeuvres à base de baies 5 puisque le
c5 sur l'emprise ça peut être une des
idées maintenant que lecavalier a bougé
il a tu as plus aux 5
donc je vous fais 3 alors maintenant on
va comprendre l'idée d'un an d'après cas
les fuites c'est dur j'ai six voix la g6
paf g6 certes mais voyez que du coup bah
ça veut dire car si ce n'était pas bon
si on joue g6 haut-anjou a g6 avec le
pion h7 puisque dans ce cas là en cas de
prise je peux reprendre du pur h
c'est bizarre
donc j'ai six est là qu arsène forcément
il prend pourquoi pas parce que s'il
prend pas peut-être que les noirs ont
joué cinq après et puis surtout bombay
et si elle planche 6 qui qu'à leurs
foutus l'ain je libère en prenant un set
en russie je libère l'action tout de
suite de matour h c'est pas la peine
d'attendre tour h4 au g4 bon câble et
pranger 6 bon mais j'ai activé un peu le
cavalier j'attaque ici 5
bon il l'a regardé très jolie carsen il
prend pas le pion h6 bien sûr parce que
si je prends prise prise fou prend
cavaliers prend sera jouable alors
faudra d'abord à enlever la tour parce
que il ya un vis-à-vis tout retour on
peut quand même regarder la manoeuvre on
va regarder tout reprend dans ce cas là
bah oui tout simplement on fait d'abord
on fait tout de suite penser voilà ce
que les tours sont protégés que je
prenne l'une ou l'autre voilà et là
c'est bon pour les noirs ça parce que là
je me retrouve avec une position scène
j'ai des tours active les blancs ou
simili moi aussi j'ai hâte à clous des 3
le pion c4 est attaqué le fou de cette
tape songé 2 c'est pas la même
donc faut surtout pas voilà faut la
pression ici des blancs car c'est mme
lagarde
ils jouent tout racheter un très joli
très jolie la tour reste active sur la
colonnade et je protège 5
voilà donc maintenant à tout moment je
peux envisager de prendre angers si ça
me plaît le plus bon donc là à nantes
joue fous ces 6 pourquoi pas alors
poussé si sans doute l'idée les noirs
c'est peut-être devenir en 8 pour sûr
protéger son cavalier voilà si on
surprotège lecavalier
il peut y avoir moins de moins de soucis
angers 6 bon c'est sans doute ça l'idée
est aussi pourquoi pas de jouer b5
pourquoi pas même si on n'a pas trop
envie de faire ça pourquoi pas parce que
d'abord c'est 5 étant prises ça c'est
embêtant mais même si c'est s'inquiétait
pas en prison des clous et en fait on
des doublerait les pions blancs ici ses
pions de doubler c'est quand une petite
faiblesse des blancs bon voit pas pour
l'instant l'énoncé nord qui sont sous
pression donc faussée 6 c'est un coup ça
permet d'avoir une plus d'options pour
le fou on peut envisager de venir en 8 /
protéger la classe g 6 bon c'est jouable
un petit coup de carsen fous ces deux
bons alors j'ai réfléchi il pas trouvé
de d'ideas coup ça empêche x 4 bon très
bien est ce que x 4 des noirs menacé
quelque chose non sans doute pas ou
peut-être que les noirs voulait jouer
tour des huit attaquants le fouet ou
valve fou si petit il peut venir
sylvie en b1 il ya tourné un échec voyez
donc une dit peut-être c'est l'idée
imaginons que les blancs jouent un coup
je parle et où j allais me diras 3 tient
il magnifie lent que j'ai bien joué à
troyes on peut envisager x 4 pourquoi
pas est ce que c'est bon pour l'idée
tour des 8es où elles font maintenant
ces deux je peux changer ça allait
s'arranger vrai de la pression peut-être
angers 6 bon je sais pas c'est pas
terrible terrible non plus
donc fou ces six pouces et deux bons
tranquille d'attentes européen et
l'arabe et 7
bon là c'est des coups et on a dix-sept
caisses qui vais faire un pcet le roi il
attend est-ce qui peut vraiment bouger
quoi un angle un c'est ça le problème
s'il bouge le cavalier bac s qui pouvait
pas bouger le cavalier tient alors
qu'est ce qui se passe sur cavalier e
set et c'est difficile né sous pression
cola là on peut faire tout reprend bon
surtout reprend g8
on joue g3 simplement empêcher toute
prise puis on veut achi s'est perdu et
sur cavaliers prend g8 est possible
aussi et dans ce cas-là sûr qu'à
l'étranger vite simplement jour et g4
très certainement menace gsm terminée
puisque le pion peut pas prendre la toya
vis-à-vis tout retour et donc on va
regagner le pion à 6 gratuit en ayant
toujours une position énorme voyez
commune de phù son forum il contrôle
tout l'un clara bessette déjà un an des
vies c'est quoi ces terribles tour g4
tranquillou patrie se pressent pas
carsen tour g4 bassa'a contrôle des
cases du cavalier ça améliore la
position de la tour sans doute l aimions
g4 parce qu elle contrôle aussi c4 on
sait jamais ça peut être utile
où il dit au noir mais aussi à toi tu
vois jamais lire la pièce de la pulsion
des pièces alors est ce qu'il ya
vraiment des menaces ici pas clair pour
les blancs à tout moment les blancs ici
à tout moment peuvent faire [ __ ]
angers 6 pour prendre puis on prend
quand même pas si c'est tout reprend je
fais foot je fais tout reprendre et on
prend et tourcoing h6 j'ai gagné un pion
je vais d'abord f3 a sans doute fait
d'abord f3 et le pion achi s'est perdue
il faut d'abord qu'on veut protéger
plongé de faut pas oublier que le team
g2 est attaqué on donc je peux l'idée
des blancs sans doute donc ils peuvent
jouer g3 aussi voilà on peut aussi jouer
g3 et du cou avait donc serré parce
qu'il fait froid avec une prise de tours
ici d'un field
donc il veut sans doute alors touché car
il protège sa il protège ses
protège-tibias meilleurs atouts sa pièce
or ce qui se passe ce sont à nantes joue
à 5
voilà c'est toujours pareil que si la
comco s'il avait joué maintenant un coup
comme le roi c'est cette méthode
innovante j'attends moi aussi pas sûr
que les blancs et encore des coups là
aussi c'est pareil il faut trouver
on peut envisager de prendre six mais
dans ce cas là on perd au 5
il aurait pu attendre encore un
ambitieux au lieu de quoi ils jouent à
cinq
bon pourquoi pas il affaiblit un peu ses
pions là pourquoi pas un peu plus jouets
vaisselle maintenant avec les noirs bon
ceci dit c'est vrai que c'est ça qui est
en prise b5 et pas envisageable bon
alors à 5 peut-être à 4 à 3 pts est il
veut faire une tour là et activer le fou
comme ça essayer d'échanger se fout ce
fut pénible apps qui si on arrive à
éliminer sous quand on subit on serait
en serez content parce que le carré gée
ci serait serait dans ce cas là
imprenable donc cela consoliderait la
position des noirs mais il ya toujours
ce pion à six qui oui mais bon c'est
vrai qu'il ya contre attaque sur scène
c'est ça l'idée les noirs tiennent à
cissac aux 2,5 c'est la contre attaque
qui protège
ah oui alors une autre des idées je
crois aussi de foot est roi mais après
tout c'est 6 pouces et de la sino des
idées si en cas de prison le 5 des noirs
il ya le fou n'est plus en prise et
sanaa certaines variantes ça peut aider
donc voilà tour g4 voyez qu'on améliore
un petit peu la position même s'il n'a
pas encore décidé quelle suite de quoi
on va faire simplement on évite des
possibilités et voilà on améliore la
position des pièces et la food & 1
pourquoi pas fou d1 alors fou d un
peut-être l'idée c'est justement de
jouer j'ai trois ans n'avait dit tout à
l'heure j'ai trois étaient pas mal parce
que on protège c'est envisageable parce
qu'on protège le g2 qui n'est plus
attaquées par le fou mais on avait le
problème de fond f3 et marvel a enjoint
fondée il ya plus frustrant on peut
jauger 3 puis fosse 3 bons mais on n'a
plus le fou pour attaquer le cavalier
donc
on peut pas tout avoir un c'est toujours
pareil donc ça suffit pas non plus
autour des 8 8
maintenant que le fou à capuche et si
son poing levé la tour qui revient
carsen poussée de ils voient comment ça
marche pas on peut rien faire donc il
revient ces deux voiliers comme il
travaille tranquillement ils se pressent
pas tourné j'évite les noirs viennent
ils sont un peu vicenç ont pu mais les
noirs les blancs fou qui trouvent un
moyen aussi de percer un roi des deux
alors là pareil c'est pas un coup il n'y
a pas de menace immédiate et j'améliore
l'impulsion de les pièges où commence à
mettre mon roi en position centrale les
noirs ici aussi de faire quelque chose à
4 et s'est créé un peu d'espacé ici
l'art est ce que les blancs pourraient
pas jouer à trois pour fixer ce pion est
comme ça du coup belle poussée sicile et
il est bloqué à la défense du pion
peut-être quoique évidemment si on prend
à quatre avec le pion à 3 à tout moment
les noirs peuvent jouer tu auras 8es
après love que les fous et jouer en
récupère le pion cadets rien donc tête
il vaut mieux le laisser en rade ce pion
3-2 tranquille où je me rapproche de mes
pions je veux peut-être protéger le
plonger de avec le roi qu'en plus j'ai
centralisée mon roi est quand même mieux
en e2 on comprend bien effectivement
qu'en c1 puisque il est vers le centre
et c'est toujours mieux participe un peu
au combat à trois alors le pion à 3 bon
il s'est affaibli ainsi s'il n'était pas
attaquable par les blancs à trois ils
commencent à l'être fou c'est un attaque
le pion c'est embêtant
ceci dit il ya aussi la possibilité
maintenant pour les noirs de jouer tour
à 8 peut-être est fou à quatre là
puisque la tour protège le fou bon ps
quant à 4 se fout
est vraiment fort rebond le flou on
revient dès 8 avec la tour et on menace
tous fous de foot et regardez il ya tout
qui saute ok alors à eux deux c'est
possible mais bon on voit pas comment
faire parce que dès qu'on bouge il ya le
cavalier g6 qui tombe bon f3 donc là car
scène malgré ces manoeuvres ont
maintenant d'en abandonner l'idée g3
s'il a jamais eu ça je sais pas mais il
joue en f3 bon alors f3 protège g2 f3
étant protégé par g2 le fou ici est
calme et ils butent contre une petite
muraille en plus ça protège la casa 4
donc se foutent pas même pas venir sera
4 dont ils pouvaient pas déjà galfond
moment-là ce fou en tout cas consolide
donc maintenant je peux l'envisager fou
prend et gagner le curage 6 ce que je
pouvais pas tout à l'heure parce qu'il
est tout reprend fallait changer les
tours et après le foot et d'eau était en
prise le pion g2 été en prise donc là
maintenant regarder autour des 8 bon
pourquoi pas alors là il laisse tomber
il laisse tomber ce qu'il ya ici là
alors maintenant qu'est-ce qui se passe
les blancs ont déjà pourrait prendre un
g6 puis on prend fou prend alors
regardez qu'est ce qui se passe
fou prend
puis on prend maintenant je prends le g6
achi c'est mort toutes trois attaques
peu 6 potentiellement aussi mais x 4
avec peut-être un peu de jeu voilà je
compte trois la casse d un bon je peux
jouer food est un échec mais après c'est
pas terrible mais surtout je peux jouer
autour des 1 3 2 et là on comprend mieux
les idées d'aaland
on a créé un petit pion qui peut être
dangereux parce que si on fait tout on
prend le pion à deux avec échec en plus
éventuellement et le pire à 3 devient
énorme candidats à la dame est donc on a
un contre jeune noir mais si ça passe
pas et c'est le problème c'est que si
cette manoeuvre ne passe pas les blancs
ont quand même ici deux pions de plus de
ce côté a peut-être même trois pions de
plus puisque les pions russie s'en va
pas trop combien défendre non plus par
mettre le foin passive passivement 17
ski pas l'idée si on veut
contre-attaquer bien sûr et dans ce cas
là les pions ici passer ça va ça va être
énorme d'autant qu'on peut envisager
sacrifier une pièce contre le pion et
les pions passé là un risque d'être
suffisant pour gagner donc c'est chaud
ça paraît quand même très très chaude et
jeanne moi j'ai déjà l'impression que
l'opposition noir et perdu voire
extrêmement difficile à tenir alors
qu'on a on n'a pas vu de grosses fautes
d'allant dans ces moments on n'a pas vu
de fautes dan enfin peut-être par le
début qu'un peu curieux mais ça c'est un
choix à la limite bon c'est curieux
psychologiquement si on tient compte du
style le quart scène mais bon sinon tour
des huit bon tour des huit je positionne
matour tout de suite en dix huit
j'invite les blancs à prendre en justice
pour jouer ma manoeuvre a échoué à 4 et
la regarder très étonnant car scène
robes ça c'est bizarre
1 parce qu'il se met en position de
sidon le fou se met en position sur x 4
de prendre un échec
donc on a moins je sais pas intuitif
comme coup voilà
revenez pas du tout en compte 8 istres
et fichiers à expliquer ce coup alors
s'il peut être une idée un joueur
revient c'est d'empêcher la manoeuvre b5
puis on prend fou prend avec échec c'est
possible ça c'est ça c'est une
possibilité
bon eh
y a pas d'échec bon mais ceci dit sur
échec on pourrait quand même joué ces
cas puisque la tour il un bon on va voir
tour 17 là un an de bons joue un coup de
quasi attentes ici protège la septième
rangée bon est ce que c'est vraiment
utile
la seule comme seul contre jordan encore
une fois en cas de prises angers 6 puis
on prend un point là c'est de jouer x 4
avec une pénétration et la regarder très
jolie de carsen fou c'est un ah ben je
menace d'éliminer ton seul contre je
tonds fameux pion à 3 voilà c'est à dire
que à la fois ceux contre je peut
s'avérer être une faiblesse voilà carsen
change de s'adapte disons ça car sienne
adapte son plan à la position and on a
cherché à se positionner il attend ah
non en fait attend ici que les blancs se
décide et les blancs mais au lieu de se
décider à faire des échanges ici puis à
se prendre une contre attaque
non non il disait ben écoute ton ta
contre attaque
c'est une faiblesse et oui on fait quoi
là parce que si ça ça tombe là tous
tentent de l'autre côté et les noirs
n'ont plus du tout contre je sais alors
qu'on va se retrouver deux pions de plus
parce que la g6 va tomber h6 va tomber
leur adoption de plus contre rien pour
les noirs ça va ça va être difficile
parce que ça va ça va aller vite
il ya déjà eu deux pions qui ont 5 ans +
f 4g 4es et 5es époux ça y est c'est
c'est la mariée quoi ces shows toi vite
protège donc il faut protéger ces
laissez obligé en fait c'est obligé
ceux-ci foutu et amène revient aux deux
tranquille
c'est énorme comme il de travail sérieux
alors là les noirs sont vissés
maintenant partout là maintenant il dit
au noir bertoua
j'aurais améliore la position pourquoi
mais il faut contrôler tout l'est toutes
les cases ici il ya plus de jeu ici j'ai
un oeil sur le contrôle de tu peux plus
bouger et j'attends mon heure pour gober
ce pion h 6 c'est horrible bon alors
ceci dit toujours trop franchisée pas
faisable à cause de cavaliers prend 1,5
donc il attend son heure maintenant
peut-être iv à eux deux parce que il
veut
tôt ou tard prendre ce cavalier parce
que s'il veut prendre les pions sans se
prendre un cavalier prendre cinq ans un
retour faut d'abord prendre bon prix de
prison va tout prendre certes mais il ya
toujours x 4 suivi de tours d1 avec
ramassage et du contrô le noir voilà
donc en jouant le 2 on évite surtout à
capri des échanges ici on est vite sur x
4 tours échec ya plus d'échec on peut
mettre la tour mais sans échec ce qui
est pas la même chose
x 4 voilà c'est laisser leur pour les
blancs par contre de jouer x 4 alors là
les noirs ne vont pas prendre à 4
puisque s'ils prennent un cadre c'est
fini pour ne plus jamais prendre le pion
lequel g6 qui se vengera toujours sur f4
sur aux cinq pardon à noter que si on
joue f4 pour protéger au sein qu'on peut
mais dans ce cas là on attaque +6 avec
le fou donc je pourrais protéger avec la
tour et on peut pas attaquer à chis
facilement voyez c'est subtil il faut il
faut garder la subtilité de la position
en évitant d'avancer ses pions en fait
car scène à maximiser la puissance de
ces fous c'est fou joua faf on en fait
et là on regarde et il fait échec il
fait échec il ya une enfilade ici sur la
tour sa force le coude et noir n'y a pas
le choix fous ces 6 sinon on perd la
qualité et c'est foutu c'est foutu parce
que là
y a pas de contrôle joue contre la
qualité est rien donc et la regarder
c'est l'heure il n'ya plus le contre jeu
par trous d1
voyez donc ce qu'on avait dit depuis le
début et donc fou pranger 6 c'est
l'heure il a tout préparé pour faire
cette manoeuvre et les noirs sont
presque même créé le pion faible ici en
fait ça je disais peut-être qu'alain ne
pouvait encore attendre même si les
blancs elle poursuit la meilleure
position il n'y avait pas y avait qu une
faiblesse en fait c'est elle c'est s est
elle est ancrée en deuxième faiblesse on
dit souvent aux échecs une faiblesse
suffit pas à une deuxième peut faire
perdre bon voilà donc là c'est chaud
faux projet six étrangers six tout tombe
tout projet 6 aïe aïe aïe ça c'est moche
ça ces bâtiments est donc là maintenant
avec les noirs font refaire la manoeuvre
on en a parlé tout le temps soit 4 c'est
l'heure il faut absolument jouer tour d
un tour à deux tours prend et essayer de
jouer ce contre je mets un joueur x 4
attention le problème c'est que le pion
à 3 n'est plus n'est plus protégé bon
alors si les blancs prennent ici ça
marche pas parce que fout échec je bouge
et le faux est perdu d'accord donc là
les blancs dont ils ramassent simplement
ok tu peux jouer autour des 1 mais moins
en attendant je ramasse en attendant que
si je prends ici
à noter j'aurai deux tours et j'ai le
pion v6 qui tombent aussi sans compter
que j'ai deux tours la regarde et qui
propose presque un escalier de maths
tour échec si le roi dans la 8ème pouget
les fameuses cas liés à des tours en
maths
voyez hein cette tour pour faire simple
cette tour contrôle 7/6 ranger et cette
tour une fois que l'on a pris h6 pour
revenir à un set pour faire un échec au
roi mais où va le roi ils peuvent ni
racisme ce cas là la torah 8
il sera mal placé et protégera plus à
trois on pourra prendre à trois
peut-être
et puis si le roi dans un des huit
balles il va falloir on va pouvoir faire
un échec là avec 1
1 - 2 qu'on puisse s'interposer une
pièce voyez donc les tours envoyé comme
l'arrière regarde ici des des noirs peut
être envahi par du verre c'est à dire
par l'action des tours blanches qui sont
quand même extrêmement puissante un
loyer comme ces tours sont puissantes
face à un roi qui est un peu dans les
courants d'air
donc la tour d un bon c'est la menace
pour les noirs ont là aussi il ya du
courant d'air du côté blanc mais ces
moines est ainsi moins nettes pascal
deuxième tour joue pas et puis on voit
bien que ce fou ici est bien placé en
pêche de venir faire des échecs le roi
peuvent toujours venir aussi entre 3 et
4 c'est pas pareil que ce roi l'acquis
bon et pièces blanches ou beaucoup plus
active et là ça fait peur et les trois
pions passé ici un trois pions passé et
la regarder si c'est terrible
c'est terrible fou prend à 3 alors ça
c'est l'horreur c'est l'horreur parce
que j'ai pris le dernier contre jeu des
noirs un joueur x 4 b / g empêcher le
contrôle avec des dalles inde s'était de
penser sans doute que ce coût était pas
possible on peut envisager fou jets
d'oeuf ou c2c possible bien sûr dans
l'idée il attaque le fou d'accord sauf
que regarder maintenant car senna tout
prévu échec
regardez où va le roi si le roi bien ces
6 imaginons qu on va on va le montrer
que c'est joli tour prend essais matin
c'est horrible
alors dès tout est protégé hélas cette
case et cette case sont contrôlés par le
pion
ce pion contrôler ces deux cases
c'est matin enfin on peut encore jouer
autour des 6 mai tour prend puisqu'il ya
aussi le pire us5 qui contrôle la case
donc seimat
c'est horrible on reprend 1,3 c'est
horrible parce que en fait on peut pas
jouer poussée de fûts ces deux bons même
si on a perdu pied on pouvait faire tout
reprendre derrière et bon ben on a un
peu de contrôle sur le roi blanc on peut
espérer s'en sortir mais ça marche pas
alors là donc du coup c'est une très
mauvaise nouvelle pour un autre tour un
bon très bien ça a l'air fort aussi
parce que maintenant bas se fout en
l'air perdu quand même parce que tout
reprend à deux échecs galles le x 3 bon
et si le fou vient en b2b tour prend à
deux quand même le fou est cloué donc ça
a l'air de gagner un fou alors
malheureusement même gagné ce fou c'est
toujours les noirs qui sont en défense
j'ai je vais sans doute je vais pouvoir
prendre h6 il faut protéger b6 mais si
je protège b6 je vais me prendre un
escalier avec un matt 1
imaginons ici que les blancs jouent bien
regarder une petite variante quand même
aller tout reprend h6 bon très bien tout
reprend à deux échecs 3,3 d'accord
menaces font c'est fou c'est un et je
m'échappe
donc on prend le fou imaginons
simplement tout reprend b6 échec nouveau
le roi
donc même la soul est les blancs bombés
sur eux et le full et noir ont quand
même des chances mais les blancs quand
même mon l'avantagent ceo qui joue pour
le gaz pie noir ils ont trop de plus en
avance je rappelle trois pions ça fait à
peu près une pièce alors trois pions
passé lié ça vaut plus comme fou voilà
même si ça va être dur hein mais on voit
bien que même là les voyez à quel point
l avantage blanc est énorme
après tours 1 voyez même la prise du pur
si c'est envisageable mais en fait car
scène joue encore mieux
je vous tout de suite road 3 l'idée bien
au clip prend le pion à 2 dans ce cas là
je sors le fou c'est fini
imaginons la variante tout reprend à
deux quand même dans ce cas là je vous
fais aussi poussé un nombre fou est
sauvé sur l'attaquant ces deux je viens
en d2 puis je viens de revin joue micha
tu as un problème on a ce cas là je
prends sans doute
par exemple je sais le coup le plus
logique salaire de abc ça c'est pas mal
quand même je sais pas ou des deux ouais
non mais tout reprend c'est quand même
le plus simple voilà et là bon mais
simplement je prends un cissé aura des
j'ai simplement belles voix l'adoption
passé lié en plus j'attaque mais si
c'est ça et si les noirs protège les six
partout raciste c'est l'horreur échec et
on n'a toujours pas fameuse
le fameux escaliers tout ça est pris le
roi noir n'a pas le choix il faut qu il
descendre par exemple on s'est vite ce
qui semble logique
maintenant tour la suite et c'est matt
ses matons peut pas on peut jouer encore
floues et huit tours prend ou tour huit
tours prend enfin on peut déposer des
pièces mais qui sont pas défendus donc
c'est un très joli match de l'escalier
voilà donc un temps menacé du fameux
mattel escaliers donc c'est horrible
après 3 3 magnifiques donc surtout
reprend j'enlève le fou donc là les
noirs tente un dernier truc fou ces deux
basses et l'autre tour qui attaquent
comme ça l'idée c'est que mon roi
bessette
une fois que j'ai pris si le football un
ancien en b2 par exemple ab dans le foot
attaque il a pas de case en fait s'il y
en b2 jeu lattaque d'accord donc l'idée
voilà c'est prendre le fou par l'autre
tourne à corfou ces deux mais ça marche
pas vous allez voir très jolie donc
arsène a tout calculé un taureau 7 c'est
fini
échec pourquoi c'est fini ben c'est
toujours pareil c'est la même idée si le
roi bien sûr la casse ces six la tour
prend 1,6 on va on va leur montrer un
ton prochain smat l'escalier et le pion
ici qui contrôle les deux cases donc là
aussi ses prix c'est matt on peut encore
jouer ou g6 faut prendre ces matins
s'échoue sur cet échec donc on voit le
roi ainsi va on sait 8 bat c'est pareil
c'est on voit bien que c'est le même
match je fais tout reprendre 6 et je
menace matt beaucoup mieux je peux jouer
roide et vite parce qu'il ya pas mal
parce que sur tours échec
je prends la tour certes ton g7 et
maintenant la menace là et plus par able
point fr c'est matt donc tous les sets
je peux pas aller sur le huitième fois
sur 6 il reste quoi il restait six il
reste à 6 pardon mais si on joue à 6
c'est quoi le problème
la tourner attaque qui le font donc je
peux prendre
6 et je menace c'est imparable faut
prendre ces 5 et le fou n'est pas
prenable
donc je peux pas prendre ce fou et
maintenant quand je vais jouer tout
reprendra deux de toute façon je sens
ancien et j'ai un deux trois pions
passée payé
c'est un massacre
toros est un homme abandonne ici dans
cette position qu'est ce qui s'est passé
dans cette partie je sais pas c'est à
dire que on est devant quand même une
partie où bach et une partie qui a l'air
à peu près normale et inéluctablement
c'est un art qui finit par perdre
voilà donc peut-être bon ce qui me
semble curieux quand même en ce début
le plus curieux c'est après e52 pas
jouer cavalier 4 il est aller s'enfermer
les pièces en inde
donc pourquoi allende ne joue pas
cavalier de quatre cavaliers ou quatre
ça a l'air quand même tout à fait
jouable fou des deux cavaliers prend
pour apprend et c'est mieux c'est les
noirs quand la paire de fous pas les
blancs et on peut toujours jouer cette
partie peut-être que car ce n est à
l'aise dans ce type de position les
blancs plus espace quand même donc un
choix d'ouverture à revoir peut-être
pour un hand qui est du coup est menée
après six parties donc le match
maintenant reparle avantage de carsen
après donc six parties moitié du match
et donc on va voir une deuxième moitié
de match passionnante et ce cas là on va
pouvoir encore une fois revenir au score
bas tout est là il aura les blancs
centre la prochaine afin d'en vérifier
je n'ai pas vérifié si après la mi match
il n'y a pas une version on verra ça à
la prochaine merci de m'avoir suivi et à
bientôt sur la tv pour suivre ce match
magnifique en train d'un écart sienne
championnat du monde 2014 entre à nantes
et qu'arsène car ces domaines après la
mi match
au revoir